throughout the cold war american
intelligence agencies used a number of
unusual tools to spy on the soviet union
tools both large and small
the tecina camera fit into a cigarette
box making it easy to sneak into
meetings unnoticed a fake silver dollar
opened up to offer a hiding space for
small secret documents the giant spy
satellite known as big bird took photos
of the ussr from space but perhaps the
most unconventional tool of the cold war
wasn't some high-tech device at all
but rather a common animal
the humble pigeon was a major asset to
espionage
thanks to their homing ability which
allows them to navigate back to a
specific home location from hundreds of
miles away pigeons made the perfect
undercover operatives for gathering
intelligence behind enemy lines in the
1970s the cia decided to take advantage
of these navigational instincts by
strapping miniature cameras to their spy
pigeons
this was operation takana and its
details remained fully classified until
2019.
the battery-operated cameras took
pictures automatically at predetermined
intervals as the pigeons flew
the cameras were attached to harnesses
the pigeons wore and could take around
140 pictures
in trial runs about half the photos were
good quality and often provided higher
detail than satellites or reconnaissance
planes since pigeons fly so much closer
to the ground the real trick was finding
a way to release the spy pigeons behind
enemy lines without anyone noticing
methods included releasing the birds
from inside a thick trench coat from a
hole in the floor of a parked car and
even from the window of a car driving 50
miles an hour
ultimately how many pigeons provided
information on the cold war remains
unknown these documents are still
classified
what's clear is that pigeons have an
incredible sense of direction
one that humans have been relying on for
millennia
but how is it that a pigeon can be so
reliable
so reliable that they've been trusted
with some of the most important
intelligence of the 20th century
how can we be so sure that pigeons
always know where to go
despite some commonly held beliefs
pigeons are in fact real
and although the common pigeon is now a
familiar sight around the world the
birds native range included europe north
africa and asia
kept in captivity they can live for more
than 15 years
and the birds are able to fly as far as
700 miles or 1100 kilometers a day
traveling as fast as 90 miles or 140
kilometers per hour
and on top of this the birds always seem
to know how to make their way back home
taken altogether these qualities have
made the birds highly valuable to humans
for thousands of years
in ancient egypt pigeons were released
from incoming ships to announce the
arrival of important visitors
in
2350 bc king sargon of akkad had his
messengers carry homing pigeons so that
if the messenger was captured the pigeon
could fly back and alert the government
pigeons served as a mail service
throughout the middle ages and were the
fastest courier service available until
the invention of the telegraph
even after new communication technology
was invented pidgins still had a place
of honor within the military
during world war one both sides of
fighters used pigeons to deliver
messages because telegraph wires were
vulnerable to attack
in world war ii the british used nearly
a quarter of a million birds across
multiple branches of the defense
services
birds of prey along the coast were even
cold so that the pigeons could return
home without being attacked by predators
british intelligence also ran a secret
pigeon service in which thousands of
birds were dropped over occupied europe
with questionnaires attached to their
legs
those working with the resistance
against nazi germany could then return
the pigeons with information about
german radar stations rocket launch
sites and troop movement
one pigeon came back with a 12-page
intelligence report sent directly to
winston churchill
pigeons were so valuable during the war
effort that they received medals for
their service
throughout world war ii the dickens
medal was awarded to 53 animals that
displayed conspicuous gallantry and
devotion to duty
and 32 of those 53 medals went to
pigeons including the american bird g.i
joe
and during the cold war spy pigeons were
released in moscow to gather
intelligence on priority targets within
the soviet union a 1976 report explained
that the shipyards at linen grad would
be one such target the area where the
soviet union built their most advanced
submarines
unfortunately for us the secrets the
pigeons may have revealed are still
classified
however we do know that the process the
military used to train these pigeons to
spy was fairly straightforward
as long as pigeons are raised in a
specific loft a building where they
spend their first few weeks of life
without leaving then progressively taken
farther and farther away from the loft
they naturally learn to navigate back to
the lofts from almost any location even
when they're hundreds of miles away
intelligence services can thus release
pigeons in a location where they will
cross over a target of interest
but how do they accomplish such a
remarkable feat
it's a question scientists have been
trying to answer for decades
a question that's been one of the
biggest mysteries of science in the last
century
some researchers proposed that the
pigeons were using a solar compass
essentially that they know the direction
the sun appears from the position of
their loft and no matter where they are
they can use that bearing to fly back in
the correct direction
one study tested this hypothesis by
shifting the internal clocks of the
birds basically by giving them
artificial jet lag to do this the
pigeons were kept in a light-proof room
and exposed to periods of light and
darkness that differed from the actual
period of light and dark outside
when those same pigeons were released
back to fly to their lofts they departed
at the wrong angle they flew in the
direction that their internal clocks
predicted and not the sun's actual
position
the experiment showed that the pigeons
definitely do use the sun as part of
their navigational system
but it's not the only thing they use
considering the fact that the birds use
the sun to navigate you might think
their eyesight is equally important
based on their repeated flights it does
seem like pigeons develop roots at least
partially based on major landmarks
but when researchers fitted the birds
with frosted glasses that impaired
vision the pigeons were still able to
return to their lofts from unfamiliar
spots over 30 miles away
though it did seem like sight was pretty
important for the final approach to the
loft
other researchers proposed that the
pigeons used the earth's magnetic fields
to navigate
in the planet's molten metallic outer
core the flowing liquid generates
electric currents and the rotation of
the earth on its axis causes the
electric current to form a magnetic
shield around the planet
scientists hypothesized that pigeons
used these magnetic fields to navigate
but didn't quite understand how the
birds might sense that magnetic
direction
then researchers developed an experiment
in which pigeons were placed in a wooden
tunnel with feeder platforms at either
end and coils of wire around the outside
the pigeons were trained to go to one
end of the tunnel if the coils were
switched on to generate a magnetic field
but if the pigeons had magnets attached
to their beaks or if the upper beak was
anesthetized the pigeon's skills were
impaired
from this they suggested the birds had
tiny particles of magnetite in their
beaks an iron oxide that is magnetized
as the name suggests which allows them
to sense magnetic fields around them
but another researcher thought that
detecting magnetic fields might be less
important than a pigeon's ability to
smell
in a 2006 study this scientist assembled
48 young homing pigeons
in half of them the nerves were cut that
helped the brain detect magnetic fields
in the other half the nerves that
carried olfactory signals to the brain
were cut
all of the birds were released 30 miles
from their loft
of those that could no longer detect
magnetic fields all but one made it home
within 24 hours
as for the birds with no sense of smell
only four made it back home
more recently a multi-disciplinary team
in italy mapped the airborne volatile
organic compounds found around a
pigeon's home these included the smells
emitted by trees the sea and even
industrial processes the researchers
used a plane flying 500 feet above the
earth the average altitude at which a
pigeon flies to aid in their
measurements
they then constructed a map that
reflected wind speed and direction
showing exactly how pigeons might make
their own mental map of their home based
on the way it smells
scientists now think that pigeons
probably use some combination of
different variables to find their way
back home and yet even with all these
clues to help them navigate the birds
still sometimes get lost
sometimes they get lost repeatedly when
being released from the same site
this is known as release site bias and
it's puzzled scientists for years
one geophysicist named john hagstrom
decided to go back and re-examine
experiments conducted by the
cornell-based biologist wt keaton
between 1968 and 1987 keaton released
pigeons from three sites in upstate new
york that were between 45 and 88 miles
away from their loft
the pigeons regularly failed to properly
orient themselves from one of the
release sites called jersey hill
that is except for on one specific day
what could cause the birds to get
constantly lost from this site except
for one time
the magnetic fields of the area
shouldn't change and neither should the
smells even if the wind shifted now and
again
to explain this weird phenomenon
hagstrom came up with a theory and a
strange one
he thought it was perhaps the sounds of
an area that the pigeons could follow
home
to test this he built an acoustic map of
each of the sites on every day of the
bird's flights
using a complex computer program that
reflected atmospheric conditions
hagstrom looked at the production of
infrasound
these are low frequency acoustic waves
below the range of human hearing less
than 20 hertz the noises can be produced
by minute vibrations in the planet's
surface such as industrial activity wind
turbines storms lightning or even
tectonic plates
and these sound waves can travel for
thousands of miles
pigeons can detect these infrasounds all
the way down to
0.05 hertz
and hagstrom had a suspicion the birds
were using these noises to navigate back
home sure enough his modeling showed
that the precise geography of the jersey
hill site the one where the birds
consistently failed to find their way
home
prevented the birds from hearing the
infrasounds from the area of their home
loft
the only day the birds were successfully
able to return home from jersey hill was
when atmospheric conditions changed the
way the sounds were transmitted allowing
the birds to hear their way home
although pigeons aren't perfect
navigators from every location their
abilities are still something humans
have respected and made use of for
centuries
while city dwellers might think of
pigeons as no more than an urban
nuisance it's clear that the birds
deserve far more credit than we give
them
pigeons despite their derpiness have
even been credited with saving hundreds
of lives during world war ii an italian
village was liberated by allied forces
in october of 1943
far earlier than expected
an air attack had been scheduled to
subdue german positions later that same
day
now that the village had been freed the
people there were now in danger of being
killed by friendly fire
the pigeon gi joe was released from the
village with a message to call off the
attack he flew 20 miles in 20 minutes
reaching allied lines just as the
bombers were preparing to take off
his actions saved at least 100 allied
soldiers lives and the lives of
countless civilians
during war communication is key
world war ii was largely won because of
the allies superior ability to transmit
and interpret constantly changing
information
and for the battle of britain the first
battle waged entirely by air this fact
could not be more true
in the series battle of britain
exclusively on nebula made by our
partner channel real engineering you can
learn about the invention of the
doubting system which brought together
technology ground defenses and fighter
aircraft in a revolution in
communication operations
the entire battle of britain series is
the peak of any of the productions our
team has made so far the 3d animations
are so good that i actually can't
believe just a few people made it and
the storytelling is captivating i
thought i knew a decent amount about
world war ii but the details in this
series has blown my mind the original
content on nebula is better than it has
any right to be
from original current events
documentaries daily news a live action
interstate game show with brian from
real engineering and sam from wendover
productions
and a feature-length film coming soon
from the incredible patrick willems the
exclusive content just constantly
surprises and impresses me
and there is more being added all the
time
and lucky for you nebula has partnered
with curiositystream to offer an
incredible deal when you sign up to
curiositystream you will also get a
subscription to nebula curiosity stream
alone is a great documentary streaming
service
but getting both is a package you don't
want to miss
and right now for a very short time you
can get both services for just 11 59 for
the entire year
that's 42 percent off the usual price
plus signing up is the single best way
you can support this channel
so go to
curiositystream.com
real science to get in on this
incredible deal and if you're looking
for something else to watch right now
you can watch our previous video about
the incredible intelligence of crows
or watch real engineering's latest video
about the mystery of the concord
airplane crash